Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new black panther 2 wakanda forever first look
breakdown there's a bunch of teasers and scenes
that they've been filming we got a look at so
we'll explain what's going on there's a whole
bunch of easter eggs here and a couple of really
big surprises about characters that i was not
expecting to be in the movie if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
they'll be filming the movie for a while so we
will be getting a bunch more scenes from the movie
learning a lot more about what's actually going on
with the film you may have also seen that it is
the anniversary of chadwick boseman's passing so
may he rest in peace a lot of the cast and
crew have been posting fond memories of him
and obviously kevin feige and ryan coogler the
director has spoken a lot about how they're
going to use the plot of black panther 2 to honor
both chadwick boseman's memory and the memory of
t'challa because they will not be recasting
the character in one of the new scenes that
we've gotten a look at is in honor of chadwick
boseman's memory like there's a big easter egg
honoring his memory so if you look here this is
just the normal throne room from the black panther
movie in avengers infinity war but what you might
notice is that there's a brand new inscription on
the pillars here that was not in the black panther
movie or avengers infinity war the inscription
here is written in their main wakandan language
they actually have multiple dialects that they
speak around the nation of wakanda but wakandan
is kind of like their common language that they
all speak on top of all the dialects and in their
language the inscription reads rest in power king
t'challa our hero it has been an honor wakanda
forever so it's them saying it's been an honor to
chadwick boseman in real life but also within the
context of the movie they're paying honor to his
passing even though ryan coogler and kevin feige
said that they would honor chadwick boseman and
t'challa's memory during the movie they didn't
say exactly what they would be doing to address
what happened to the character within the mcu
but i think logically a lot of us were assuming
because namor seems like he's such a big part of
the film as an antagonist that they would just
pin his death on neymar i'll address that again in
a second when i talk about the other name or stuff
that we got to look at but the next really big
scene that we actually got to look at this first
look is in cambridge massachusetts mit they're
filming the movie in atlanta but they're making
it look like mit university and as you probably
saw it's all about introducing a really huge new
surprise character i totally didn't expect to
be in the movie so this is shuri in the middle
of a huge chase scene on a motorcycle jumping it
onto a military tank while also being chased by
the local police so you ask why is shuri having
a huge chase scene through mit it's all about
the surprise brand new character riri williams
played by dominique thorne that's right ironheart
is going to get her introduction or version
of her origin story during black panther 2.
this is the scene of shuri and okoye spying on her
from a distance just trying to figure out what her
deal is like you can see dominique thorne's riri
williams just walking across campus in the middle
of the day and this is what she's actually going
to look like during the movie they haven't said
how big her character's supposed to be during
the film but these scenes that they're filming
here are scenes taken directly out of her origin
story with a few minor changes in the comics she
was an mit undergrad in their engineering program
and getting to the iron man of it all because she
kind of flows from the iron man mythology in the
comics the whole connection between her armor and
iron man their characters you remember during the
first iron man movie at the beginning when he's
getting that award in vegas they read a little
of his history up to the point when he's a child
when he goes through school how he created all
these advanced engineering designs when he was
just a little kid then eventually graduated from
mit when he was only 16 years old big deep cut
reference if you remember that movie real genius
from the 80s it's a cool val kilmer 80s movie
imagine tony stark is a character during that and
because of when that movie was made robert downey
jr could have actually shown up during that just
a bunch of really smart kids in an engineering
program getting to all kinds of trouble riri
williams doesn't have any of the boozy nerdywell
vibe of tony stark she does get into a lot of
trouble but she's not quite as misbehaved as tony
stark was growing up but just like him and like
shuri in the mcu she creates all these advanced
armor designs dumpster dive home brew builds
herself a pretty decent armor suit mark one
while she's in the middle of term at mit so you
remember iron man's mark one in the cave seen him
coming out it was very low five version that he
just cobbled together with what he had available
she kind of does her own version of that
scene but some of her designs incorporate star
tech cast off stuff that she's managed to
salvage so when she tests the armor like she
has her own version of the cave scene busting
out and flying around it shows up on iron man's
detection systems and he goes to check out what
the hell is going on just playing it off like
he's paying a casual visit to his alma mater you
have to imagine the scene kind of like when he was
showing off the barf tech during captain america
civil war going back to his school issuing more
grant money for the university to just disguise
what he was really doing there but a bunch of
time went by they had their own civil war ii event
in the comics he winds up almost dying putting his
body into stasis activating a digital ai backup
of his consciousness now as far as we know robert
downey jr isn't coming back to the mcu which is
why it seems like they're sort of incorporating
more black panther wakanda and shuri stuff in the
iron man role that he served during the ironheart
comics but after a big time jump iron man's ai
consciousness shows up to riri williams while
she's still tinkering with her own armor designs
and offers to mentor her finance her research
until she eventually creates the ironheart armor
from the comics taking that name so in the black
panther 2 mcu version of this origin story they're
adding in all the shuri black panther and wakanda
stuff there were a lot of people early on after
the first black panther movie came out and they
saw that she was basically like a version of iron
man tony stark inside wakanda saying why don't
they just make shuri the mcu version of ironheart
because she already creates all these armor suits
that are on par with iron man's designs using
vibranium she's like the smartest person on
the planet next to iron man and eventually reed
richards when we meet him during the new fantastic
four movie but then marvel announced that they
were doing a full-blown ironheart disney plus
series in an armor awards series with rhodey
and chadwick boseman passed away so marvel's
plans make a little more sense now with the way
they're changing all these adaptations from the
comics shuri's path in the comics originally was
to become the next black panther after t'challa
passed a mantle to her that happened while he
was still alive in the comics at the time he just
felt like being king and being black panther
was too much for him to do both jobs at 100
so he passed the mantle of black panther to her
and just focused on being king of wakanda for a
brief period kevin feige and ryan coogler already
made it very clear that they're not going to
recast t'challa in the mcu meaning that the mcu
needs a new black panther in right now without
confirmation of a multiverse version of killmonger
showing up or a secret t'challa love child with
some woman surfacing shuri is the best candidate
for that so that's probably the main reason why
shuri just isn't going to become the ironheart
of the mcu but clearly what it seems like they're
changing about ironhearts backstory is that
instead of iron man's digital consciousness
showing up to peep what she's doing with stark
tech armor designs it's shuri and akoye showing
up to see what she's doing with her technology
because this is mit and this has a deep connection
to the iron man character and so much of her
character flows from iron man in the comics i
said there'll probably be some easter eggs for
iron man during all this like tony stark did
fund a bunch of free education for a ton of kids
at mit and other big schools ton of scholarships
so it's possible that mcu riri williams got
into mit on a version of the stark industries
internship program like the big spider-man joke
the internship started out as a fake thing just an
excuse that they used to trick aunt mae before she
learned the truth about peter working with iron
man and the avengers then inside the mcu movies
they actually turned the joke into a real thing
taking those funny pictures to help provide some
plausible evidence to hide spider-man's identity
turns out that didn't work too well but they did
wind up using this funny picture as an emotional
call to action for him during avengers end game
to solve the time travel riddle but because he's
dead in present day and robert downey jr doesn't
seem like he's rushing to come back any time soon
they're using shuri the black panther characters
as part of rio williams origin story so when she
eventually creates her full ironheart armor
like her version of the mark 3.0 in the comics
it'll probably be more inspired by vibranium
and wakandan technology like they're shifting
her character from more of an iron man character
to more of a black panther character and they'll
probably connect the ironheart disney plus series
with the armor war series bringing it back around
to the iron man of it all but the armor war series
will mostly be based on the original comics during
which justin hammer buys a bunch of illegal copies
of iron man's armor designs including the really
advanced models they keep bringing back those
marvel phase one characters like the abomination
so they might bring justin hammer back for the mcu
version of armor wars but i'm expecting roadie to
cameo during the ironheart series when they get
to that like his cameo scene during falcon and
winter soldier so i'm also expecting ironheart
to then show up during the armor war series at
some point but moving into more of the black
panther versus namor of it all the new namor
stuff that we got to look at recently is them
filming more underwater scenes for the movie
for more of the atlantean stuff i've already done
a bunch of videos about namor in the movie so i'll
link them below in the description there have
been a bunch of reports about tenoch huerta from
narcos mexico playing their mcu namor and them
playing it as more of an antagonist in the mcu
them doing namorita along with a couple atlantean
warlords from the comics so the way they're just
presenting his character it really does seem
like they intend on paying off that easter egg
from avengers end game when okoye ignored the
quote-unquote underwater earthquake the reading
on those tremors it was a mild subduction
under the african plate do we have a visual
how are we handling it net it's an earthquake
under the ocean we handle it by not handling it
turns out maybe she should have checked that out
like i said my assumption right now for the way
they're going to handle t'challa's character
transitioning to the realm of the ancestors is
it'll have something to do with namor some sort
of retribution that he's seeking the rivalry
between their two characters goes way back in the
comics speaking of doctor strange i do have more
spider-man no way home videos that i'm working on
that'll post soon in my what if episode 4 video
that's gonna be the doctor strange episode that'll
post on wednesday just like normal make sure you
have alerts enabled for my channel so you don't
miss those and click here to learn what's going
on with the sinister six during spider-man no way
home and click here for my full spider-man no way
home trailer breakdown thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe in wakanda forever!